and as scientists around the world race
to find a vaccine for kovat 19 some are
considering a controversial method to
speed up the process one headline from
ABC News reading quote injecting healthy
adults with live coronavirus provides
moral dilemma and faster path to vaccine
joining us now is dr. Jeanette Nash what
she is a family and emergency medicine
physician and a Fox News medical
contributor dr. Nashua always good to
see you thanks for being here this
morning we have a lot of questions one
on injecting health yes you can see with
the vaccine to find a vaccine
obviously this piece was pointing out
the moral dilemma with doing that but
you've got healthy people all over
saying or or if they tested positive for
the antibody saying you as me use me to
help find a vaccine so we can get out of
this well that's great that we have lots
of volunteers but we have to remember
Sandra that it takes about 10 to 15
years to get a vaccine on the market and
it cost millions of dollars so we are
moving at an extraordinarily fast pace
to get it down into one and a half years
we have to understand that vaccines have
to go through trials phase one phase two
and phase three and two doctors as
reported in the Journal of infectious
diseases said let's instead of using the
regular Phase three trials
let's just use what's called a human
challenge trial meaning after we've
checked for safety and effectiveness and
dosage inge let's just indirect inject
it straight into patients but the
question is we are knowingly asking
volunteers to inject themselves with a
deadly pathogen that could you know
potentially kill them and on top of that
I am seeing so many patients young
patients with heart disease with strokes
with pulmonary embolisms blood clots in
their heart and their lungs so there's
definitely a risk this is a bit of an
ethical dilemma that we have to also
take into consideration very important
developments there this is the Wall
Street Journal scotlock Gottlieb this
morning America needs to win the vaccine
race right in quote Ovid 19 altered
world history it's now evident that
public health is part of national
security a successful vaccine will allow
Americans to reclaim the country's
safety
and sovereignty the first country to
reach this prize will be the first
nation to recover so to your point the
race is on to find that vaccine by most
estimates we're still a year to 18
months out I want to ask you also now
about the talk of this possible new
treatment pep the the active ingredient
in a heartburn drug that we all know
pepcid what are we learning on that with
obviously putting out the warning to
people listening that nobody's saying to
run out and buy this if you're suffering
from symptoms of koban 19 but what are
we learning about its effect on kovat
patients sure so actually there's a
study here in New York where patients
are being put on famotidine which is an
over-the-counter medicine some people
take it for heartburn like if they eat
you know something spicy or with like
tomato sauce and they have some
heartburn they'll take that medicine so
there's a study showing if patients are
put on famotidine and hydroxychloroquine
will they have a better outcome and the
reason why doctors got this idea to run
this study here in the United States is
because in China doctors noticed that
patients that were put on famotidine
versus patients that were put on a more
expensive type of antacid outlived those
who were put on the more expensive
antacid that's what why they decided oh
let's let's check this out let's see if
this is gonna work but basically what
happens is famotidine also known as
pepcid it acts sort of like a decoy for
the virus so when the virus enters this
system it's gonna interact with
famotidine and it won't have the
opportunity to replicate and cause
severe illness so it's being studied
it's definitely something to look at
it's being given in very high doses in
this trial that's going on here in New
York it's not a harmful medicine to take
in high doses so that's always important
to make sure we're not doing any harm to
our patients during this study but hey
we need to try and see what works and if
it's effective that's fantastic but it's
gonna take some time to see the results
of this study as always if you have
questions ask your health care provider
about that final thoughts on dr. Burks
saying this I meet the press over the
weekend social distancing will be with
us through the summer to really ensure
that we protect one another as we move
through these phases
so with a few seconds that we have left
dr. Nashua use your thoughts about what
the summer is going to look like as we
start to see parts of the country reopen
I think if everyone adheres to the CDC
guidelines and we can definitely open up
slowly smartly in phases phase one phase
two and phase three remember the goal is
to protect high-risk population is the
most vulnerable in phase one and two
most vulnerable have to still shelter at
home but it's very important to make
sure that we adhere to the six-feet
guidelines because this virus is very
highly infectious and contagious and we
want to definitely prevent the spread of
this infection from one person to
another by taking these very simple
steps and as the weather gets warmer the
sun's shining in so many areas of the
country gets harder and harder but we
hear you doctor thank you very much dr.
Nash what